hey it's evan and today i'm doing
another one of my fiverr gigs i am
reviewing a website from
gene underwood and his website is sct
power
dot us so we're gonna check that out i
don't know if i've done a us
website review before so this might be a
first should be fun
so
here we go sct power
sliding cord engine next generation of
clean burning fuel efficient compact
engine design
so
my first thought initially is i'm not
exactly sure
what
this is about so it's an engine
leading with the
picture of the engine
doesn't mean much to me right so we want
to lead here with the benefits like why
is this such a great new engine
this
maybe to a highly technical person so it
depends on the audience to a highly
technical person this might make sense
but to me i don't know
you know what's going on here why this
is better than other engines and so
again when you're making that this is a
common issue for a lot of people making
a presentation
you focus on the technical details and
not the benefits right so before i even
care about what this thing looks like
and this may be the greatest invention
in the world i have no idea before
you tell me about the invention and how
it works
tell me what it does
right tell me the benefits of what it's
all about and that'll get me asking well
how does it work why is it different
right when you lead with this it makes
it more confusing so some of the
elements are here it's just this should
be lower down on the page or in a
different page
uh let's scroll down and see
welcome
excited to announce the formation of the
company promote the next generation of
engine design simple efficient compact
design of this engine it's potential
applications as many industries our
business plans design and build the
engine target small industrial off-road
vehicle markets seeking qualified
investors for first-round funding
develop and prototype the engine use a
contact us page
to be part of it okay so this is
targeting investors and again investors
i used to be in the investment uh
business venture capital raising half a
million to 15 million dollars for
companies
this is not the way we want to start off
talk about the benefits and then this
shouldn't even be on the home page i
don't care about what your engine looks
like until i know that it's going to
change the world so hit me high level
first
so these are better compact simple
design clean burning modular fuel
efficient
each engine block pictured in animated
video
so like this
doesn't matter
right again too technical
this is what i'm more concerned about
the simple design of the engine will
reduce manufacturing costs as well as
provide extended life of the engine over
current engine design this is awesome
how much
so how much has it reduced the cost of
manufacturing the engine
and how much does it provide extended
life you're making both claims here i
want some numbers and some data to back
it up this i don't care about the
technical how from an investor point of
view doesn't matter it's going to get
into the due diligence as investors look
at it they may hire their technical guys
to comb through it this is what they're
going to care about but investors don't
care about this they care about this and
give me more data as to why
clean burning unlike previous rotary
designs the unique shape of the piston
affords 100 seal as the pinion piston
rotates in the block
so i don't know what that means and i
don't know how that means that it's
clean burning i maybe i'm i'm ignorant
but i mean you're going to get that with
investors right investors are not going
to be
super knowledgeable about your product
so
i kind of understand what clean burning
means but i don't understand this so
again take out the technical stuff i
don't care about the shape of the
pistons i don't know what this this 100
seal means talk to me how it's clean
burning and what the benefits are
modular engine block modules are
designed to be stacked and mated to each
to each other up to the sheer strength
of the power shaft again too technical
doesn't make sense to me with two
ignition cycles per block per evolution
the power derived from this design is
twice that of an equivalent displacement
engine i don't know what displacement
engine is but
twice the power of a normal engine
that's great again this is what we focus
on not the rest of it
and i don't know if modular is the
benefit it's more power
and the fuel efficient by using
electronic friction plates between
stacking engine blocks again
does not help me at all
this gives the power benefits of a large
displacement engine with the fuel
efficient benefits of a small
displacement engine
okay so
again this is more helpful than the
first part so for all of you who are
trying to build a website and trying to
build the presentation document to go
after investors again what we want to
know is what the heck does your
invention or your product your service
do
what are the main benefits
why do i care about this i don't care
about the technical details yet tell me
why this is an important invention and
then let me dig into the details if i'm
curious okay so that's what this website
it's it's a good start it's a good start
just changing the warden around
and adding more the benefits in will
help
i definitely take this off powered by
website builder godaddy
patent pending that's great
so usually when you're looking at um
an investment document
the first thing we're going to look at
is the executive summary so we don't
really have an executive summary here
maybe you want people to use a contact
to find out more about it but give me a
higher level overview of what you're
trying to do like the size of the market
your your plan just an overview
something that if you know your
competition reads
it's not the end of the world but i need
to be sold in the executive summary
before i want to take the next step
beyond that what investors are going to
look at is the team so let's see the
about us
mission statement create a deeper
create a cleaner planet one engine at a
time
okay about the owner my name is jean i
grew up watching my father create an
oral industry service company based on
adventures he created
so i like the personal story uh i might
you know have a picture of your dad and
or you and your dad
big blocks of text make it a little bit
hard to read so chunk that up a little
bit and two or three paragraphs
i have a degree in computer science and
i've been working in the it industry for
the last 20 years
so this is something that's going to
cause me some concern if i'm an investor
maybe what you're really looking for is
not just money but you need somebody to
run this company
and the biggest concern i would have is
one
does this thing work
right so it's great to have a patent
it's great to claim that it works it's
great to say that it's twice the power
of a regular engine
but give me some proof show me studies
that you've done show me case studies
show me testimonials show me somebody
with credibility saying that this thing
works because
you know i believe that i believe that
this works
the challenge is
investors are pitched all the time with
people who say they have the next
greatest thing and it doesn't work so
this is what you're being lumped into
that's the problem so you need to show
that it is working that there is
momentum so give me some credibility
maybe you already have it it's just not
being shown on here
my next concern after that is you have a
background in computer science and i'm
in the it industry for the last 20 years
you know what do you know about engines
and what is your experience in building
a business that's going to be my issue
so if i'm an investor i give you i don't
know what you need i don't know what
you're asking for give you half a
million dollars to launch this business
if you've never run a company before and
you don't have experience in building
engines then
that's going to be a problem
right that's going to be an issue of why
would i give you this money so
what i'd suggest for you is to build a
team up around you right somebody who
has more business experience who's going
to run this company it gives me a little
more
you're reducing my risk
right you're reducing my risk a lot so
even if i like the idea if i buy that
this thing works i buy your credibility
statements from your testimonials and
case studies i buy all that i'm worried
who's going to actually run this company
and can you be
a ceo or not
target market potential markets
um
can i click through on these so let's
click you see an airplane so it's just a
plane so
okay i mean i guess i got a general
sense of
what you're doing here but i don't know
the size of these markets
and it's kind of locking in details i
get that you want people to contact you
to
learn more
but
i don't know if there's enough on this
yet to make an investor want to contact
you
contact us page save a tree use this
form it's good some social media
channels let's see what's happening here
and
i think i thought i saw some news at the
front there yeah you have some news here
so you launched a crowdsourcing campaign
contribute let's check this out
fundraiser.com
practical solution would do co2
emissions
so already this is a better start
than what you have on your home page
new engine new concept engine design
into reality
reduce co2 emissions by up to 50 over
current engine design so that's great
right this is great i don't remember
seeing that on your original page but
again you got to back that up right it
should reduce people throw out tons of
claims
why is this actually going to work
you see a picture this is great i mean
this is missing from
your initial page i don't know anything
about you from your home page again i'd
try to have maybe something about you
with the engine or you with showing some
kind of
you know mechanical engineering
background something
so a lot of the same information here
your story all that stuff okay
twitter
so
yeah i mean it kind of looks like you
just threw up a twitter page you have a
twitter page you got some tweets going
up trying to promote the social media
campaign
facebook page
nothing really happening there i mean
it's a way for people to reach you if
they want that's fine you're not you
know pushing it too much
but again going back to this page okay
this is this is what we're the point of
the review and this is what you want to
get going
to summarize
you need to first show me why this is
important okay don't get into technical
details
show me why it's important tell me about
what you're trying to build why this is
super important then get into the
benefits
right tell me why this is
going to happen the the
the main things that by using this
engine the world would be a better place
right you've started going on to it here
with these take out the technical
stuff people don't care about it yet i
know you think this is this is this is
the core this is what it is this is why
it's so important but i'm telling you
investors don't care about this stuff
yet they need to understand
the benefits first before the how
okay
back this up
has 100 seal
doubles the power of an engine whatever
that was extends the life of an engine
back that up you can't just throw it a
claim you have to back it up with some
data to show me why this is gonna happen
and some testimonials okay then a little
bit more about your plan what your you
know path to market is
who is on your team if it's somebody
besides you build up your credibility a
little bit more
and then you can have a page that shows
a little bit about the patent and all
that stuff
i'm excited by this it sounds like a
promising new technology and
i hope that you can leverage some of
what i've suggested here to build a more
powerful presentation because it's it's
a shame there's so many great inventions
out there that could really change the
world that just that just die on the
inventor's table
because they didn't do a good job in
getting the word out and promoting
themselves properly
and
i get that you know you're a technical
person and maybe not a marketer and
maybe that that means trying to get
somebody on board who believes in what
you're doing and who has marketing
skills to help you build this thing up
but i'm excited with this let me know
how it goes um i'm not a huge engine
person but if this will help you know
make the world a better place and
provide jobs for people as well then i'm
all of for so for those of you who want
to check it out you can go to what is it
sctpower.us
if you guys like this video give it a
thumbs up below you have some comments
as well leave it in the comment section
i'll be reading those afterwards and you
can click on my face there in the top
right of the video to subscribe to the
channel thank you guys so much and i'll
see you soon